[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم غارات اسرائيليه على
قطاع غزه استشهاد ثلاثه عشر بينهم ثلاثه
من قيادات الجهاد الاسلامي وزوجاتهم وعدد
من ابنائهم الجيش الاسرائيلي يرفع درجه
التاهب في المنظومات الدفاعيه في جنوب
وشمال اسرائيل
ومعاريف تنقل عن نتنياهو قوله ان اسرائيل
تستعد لحرب على جبهات متعدده والفصائل
الفلسطينيه تتوعد وتحمل الاحتلال
المسؤوليه وتؤكد انه سيدفع الثمن
المكتب الاعلامي الحكومي في غزه يقول ان
الاحتلال اغلق المعابر الى القطاع مما
ينذر بازمه انسانيه مؤكدا ان الغارات
الاسرائيليه ادت الى تدمير 11 وحده سكنيه
بشكل كامل داعيا المجتمع الدولي لاتخاذ
موقف واضح ضد العدوان الاسرائيلي حسب قوله
الامن الباكستاني يعتقل رئيس الوزراء
السابق عمران خان عقب توجهه الى المحكمه
العليا بالعاصمه اسلام اباد حيث كان من
المفترض ان يمثل امامها ومسؤول امني يقول
ان اعتقاله جاء في واحده من تهم الفساد
التي يواجهها
وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه تنقل عن مصادر ان
النجمه ليونيل ميسي سيلعب الموسم المقبل
في السعوديه
المصادر قالت ان صفقه انتقال اللاعب
الارجنتيني حسمت وان قيمه العقد استثنائيه
وضخمه للغايه الى اللقاء